Around 2050, which is not far away
the proportion of the elderly will be
greater than the young
and this is a problem
My son said you are lucky
Why?
He said
"you are lucky because you raised your children already"
"raising children is difficult now"
Indeed, it will be difficult
However, we are not used to cultivating the correct values
We delegated it to others
delegated it to others
Now, it is your responsibility
But, in general, you encourage reproductive
your articles, tweets are clear on this
I encourage reproductive with limits, not absolutely
What are your limits?
the limits, for example,
having more than 4 children is too much nowadays
This is Suqrat from Thamanyah
and I am Omar Al- Jeraisy
hosting transformation leaders, entrepreneurs
and opinion leaders
and talking with them about
Vision 2030 objectives and development
Our guest for today is Dr, Rushood Al- Khraaif
specialized in demography and demographics
and we talked a lot about this concept in the introduction
what is the relationship between population and economy?
Maybe this is an unexpected episode in Suqrat Podcast!
Because of the stereotype of the 2030 Vision
that most of it is about the economy
When we read the Vision document,
we find that the first topic is about
creating a Vibrant Society
so, we feel it is important to talk about the community
How did it interact with the Vision?
What is the positive and negative impact
that society experienced in the past period
with
the developments, programs, and goals of the Vision?
We also talked about values, identity,
female work and its impact on the family,
fertility rates,
and a lot of things related to the society?
that we feel has a direct and indirect connection
with the Vision, programs, and initiatives
and we concluded the podcast as usual
with your valuable questions
such as,  what is the impact of low fertility rates?
what are the causes of divorce?
and
how do our guest see the migration
to Riyadh from most cities of the Kingdom
is it something positive or negative?
I will leave you with the dialogue
Welcome Abu Muhammad,
it is an honour and pleasure to have you
welcome to you and the audience
Thank you
It is a nice program and a great initiative
I highly appreciated your wonderful initiative
Thanks a lot, Abu Muhammad
By the way, my son watches your podcasts
and when I told him your name he was surprised
that means that he was the one who convince you
he was so excited and said its a great opportunity
Our pleasure
I'm so happy to be here
Many Thanks
I'll start by asking you
about the cultural shock
that you exprienced when you  talked
with your higher study professor
about the number of children
and he said it is not feasible,
having children doesn't worth it
Thats true
tell me the story of that shock
I traveled there and it was different at that time
It was a different time, with different impressions
It was the end of 1979
no, it was the 1980
I was coming from a rural area
I am from Howtat Bani Tamim
Welcome
My pleasure
One of the professors
who taught us
and he didn't have children for quiet a time
and there were social meetings
that were managed by the department
so, my colleagues and I were surprised
and I have the courage to ask him
so, I told him, in our culture
if the person get married
and didn't have children for 5 years
that means there is a reason
so, what is the your reason
for not having children for 5 years or more
He is married but hasn't have children yet!
right
He said, I found that the cost
of raising a child is very high
and I need to reconsider the whole subject
and do planning so, he gave me a number
He told me a very huge number
and said,
the cost of raising a child
as he calculated it
to the best of my memory
200,000 $
This is the cost
of raising a child until he is 18
and it is a huge amount
he said what is the return?
of having children!
This takes us
to an economic theory
about return on investment vs cost
to explain having repriductive behavior
and it is a financial explanation
that the person unconciosouly
sometimes he doesn't set and calculate
but unconsciously
he thinks
what are the benefit and return
of having children?
and what is the cost?
so, if the cost increases
as well as the economic projects
maybe this will upset the audience
If the cost is higher than the return
we mostly don't take the decision
whether is it an investment decision,
going to the university decision,
or marriage decision
and the psychological factors
the return...
We don't mean a purely financial return
or money
but it could be sometimes
a psychological return
for example, when a child is sick
On a dark night
and wake up to take him
to the hospital.
This is a psychological cost
All of these costs are taken into account
But these are
your perceptions recently
But at that time you had
different reaction
No
What was your reaction
when you hear his words?
I felt he was wrong
I felt..............
I didn't imagine........
there is a person who would think
this way
I even was surprised that somebody set and do calculation
putting human
in a financial equation
After experience
and teaching demographics courses
started easily discussing these issues
and time changed as well
I don't know what is
your point of view
about the cost-benefit
of having children
and human beings
If we discuss it from
social and religious context
in our culture for example,
when a baby is born,
his life is created
that's right
sustenance is in the hands of Allah
'' Marry women who are loving and very prolific,
for I shall outnumber the peoples by you"
All of these motivations
When it comes to someone
Who grew up and absorbed them
and said to him
having a child is not feasible
exactly
They have a shock
We are glad to have you today
to discuss a topic
we never talked about it
in Soqurat Podcast
which is demographics and the society file
and society changes that
are results of Vision 2023
and the story of this episode
started when I was talking
with my uncle, he has some concerns
on some changes that happened
so he said, why you didn't
host a guest talking about
social matters in Souqrat
Our families changed,
our children didn't defy us
and they became teenagers
go out without permission
So, I said we don't discuss these topics
We discuss topics related to the Vision
So, he said, doesn't  the Vision related to the society
when He asked me this question
it looks like he woke me up from a mental image
from my imagination
that the Vision is only about economy
Agree
but if you open the Vision document
you will find the first topic is
Vibrant Society
yes
So, he made me aware off
So I searched for a specialized person
who can help us in documenting
the story of societal transformation
and understand it more.
There are some positive parts
And other parts may be negative
and there are impressionist parts
everyone has his own impression of it
so we are glad to have you today
and before we enter the 2030 Vision Part
and the Saudi society
let's understand generally
What is the relationship of
the society
and population with the economy?
The population's relationship
with the economy  is a tight relation
the population impacts the economy
and vise versa... in workforce supply
in demographics changes
especially in the population age
Which causes an aged society,
impact the supply of workforce,
Impact the increasing of elderly,
and impact the young people
all these changed
we are talking about
happened in the Kingdom
and other countries such as,
Japan, Italy, Spain
are suffering a lot due to demographics changing
Is it a gift or a curse?
We see countries suffer from
poverty and tragic conditions
because they have a large population
that's right
and other countries attract immigrants,
brings the workers
only to cover the human resources gap
so, is the large population a gift or a curse?
It is the role of the population policy
And I hope that the population policy
in the Kingdom
is announced soon
because it took long time
maybe 15 years
under discussion in corridors of
offices, departments, and councils
The population policy has to see
the available resources
and the development potentials
and population growth in the country
so, there will be a balance
between the population
and the development potentials
some poor countries
there is no proportion
between the available resources
and the fast population growth
and we have a lot of examples
in the world
but sometimes
some countries like Japan
their economic resources
are limited
especially the natural resources
but by using their minds,
wisdom,
and anti-corruption
The existence of
effective civil institutions
the country can
provide
the economic potential for the population
even if it poor of natural resources
Unfortunately, in the Arab world
without mention
there are some countries
which have ample resources
and high potentials
But they have management problem
and, may be, prevalence of corruption
in the country
limit the possibility
of providing a decent life
for their population
so they suffer from unemployment
poverty and etc
As a result
of not managing these resources properly
and the prevalence of corruption
You had a tweet in August 2020
said, that fertility rates
in most countries are
less than two children
which means
the population growth
will stop in 2100
you are expecting
the global population growth
in the planet earth
in 2100
some expect it in 2060
Before!
yes before
So, what will happen
if the population growth stope?
in the planet
Some countries will be greatly impacted
especially the developed countries now
Because they will be aged countries,
their workforce will reduce
dramatically
it will have a great impact
Gross domestic product,
and the economic growth
They have to find solutions either by encouraging
a woman to have children
and this is one of the most
challenging issues
Because once a woman used to
a certain lifestyle and culture
it is difficult to change her behavior
Because changing the behavior is difficult as you know
Behavior changing needs time
and motivations.
Even if you do little change
and the fertility rate increased a little
it will not  provide enough workforce
for continuous economic growth.
The other choice could be
immigration
Open the door to immigration
is a very sensitive subject
Because it contributes
in changing the demographics
especially in the European countries
where there is Islamophobia, meaning
fear of developing countries in general
especially Muslims that they change the demographics
in the country
Japan is  cautious
in opening the door to immigration
Although, it lives a demographics catastrophic
because there workforce decrease
and number of elder people increasing
If their number decreased means
they need health care
They need health care
They need good support
and health care for elderly is more expensive
than it for young people
This is an introduction to our subject today
which is the social implications
either because of the vision
or coincide with the Vision
Because some of them
are not necessarily related to the Vision
there is globalization before the Vision
and other many things
all of them impacted
the Saudi society today.
You have an article in May 2022
titled
World Population Growth
between contraction and inequality
and you said
that many Arab countries
witnessed a declined
to a point where Israel has a higher rate
than Jordan, Syria, Lebanon
and Saudi Arabia
Today, recent figures were published
that the fertility rate has decreased
in Saudi Arabia, reaching 2.1
which is the number that is
hardly adequate for substitution
Each 2 died, 2 are born
so, talk to me about what happened
the fertility rates in Saudi
You said, we need to encourage
the woman to reproductive
but today we have the opposite
there is a dramatic decline
in the fertility rates
right
Before, we talk about this point
I want to continue in the previous topic
and point that if the demographics circumstances
continue in the Kingdom
continue at the same rate
around 2050, which is not far away
the proportion of the elderly will be
greater than the young
and this is a problem
Can you imagine that
around 1992,
49% of Saudi population were under the age of 15
Now, they  are 30% or less
this is a huge drop
which means 19 point, 19%
drop in young people proportion
so, if we reach 2050
the elder people will be more
of course
if we ask, why this happened?
the situation and demographics transformation
happening in the kingdom
and in some countries
happen as a result of
the developmental changes
not as a result of direct government intervention to limit reproductive
let's simplified it Abu Muhammad
Developmental changes is a bit scary word
Developmental changes for example,
the country, with its great developmental plans,
made a change in our life
in terms of education,
female enrolment in education,
enrolment in labor market,
improve the quality of life
openness to the world,
family style change,
I mean the family concept has changed
All of these made a change
Also, infant mortality rate
in the past, many families were giving birth
to big number of children
hoping that there might be
enough of them left.
Because sometimes
infants mortality rate is very high
So, if you ask elder people
or those who are at our age
you will find his name
repeated many times
they gave his name then die many timed
So. improving community health in the country
improving the quality of life
education enrolment
All of this led
to a change in customs and traditions
People move (this is very important) from villages and desert
to live in cities
Cities culture and life is totally different,
even the cultural values which are
different also than in the rural and dessert
that encourage and enhance the big family
because this has sort of pride of big family
and of its many kids
but in the civilised region
the cost is  high
raising children is difficult
It is not like the rural area
you give birth and your cousin and your neighbours
cooperate and help you as a family in raising kids
In the cities, the problem is big
because you raise your children on your own
you are responsible on them
and the place is small
They cant play inside apartment
If the number of children increases
you have to move to a larger house
and this also cost more
so, the cost of child that we
talked about it at the beginning
starting to build up
because you are raising a child
until he become 18, 20 or more
and there is no return
In the rural there is a return
herding sheep
reaping the sowing
helping the family
or work in craft profession
so the society developed
and there is a specialities
not general professions
The speciality calls
for a good education for children
to enable them to find work
and this is why the unemployed need to be directed
to specific specialists
encourage them...
All these matters
in addition, if we deep dive into the details
for example, the cost/value of a child
and care elderly parents
totally changed
in the past, they hoped
and a lot of them still, alhamdullilah
especially in our society hope the child, either girl or boy
take care for their parents
This is a medical insurance policy
Now, with existence of social security,
some social institutions,
others, and planning for post retirement
reliance on children
to support their parents
is less than before
and this is a global pattern
its not only us who have this situation
the European countries preceded us
and we follow them
and I hope that the social institutions
have some resilience and the islamic and Saudi family
more coherent than the Europeans families
We don't advocate to weaken the cohesion
of the family
Now, you explain the reality
so, is it good or bad?
because they are positive stuff
but the final outcome is less reproductive
Is it good or bad?
Did you mean less reproductive?
Yes.
fertility rate decline dramatically
was surprising
because we don't have family planning
and no government support for this orientation
We were predicting that  it will continue
at higher rates
especially there are motivations
for the reproductive
We have maternity leave,
Real Estate Development Fund
to grant families
and prefer the married families,
give them a priority.
It doesn't cover unmarried people
right
so, this is why a person
that the fertility rates
decline that fast
I believe that now we have pause
especially from the authorities
and formulate a policy based
on studies
because the statistics also may be
inaccurate
because we have many residents
A lot of residents are women
and they don't reproductive
and if you calculate the total fertility rates
it will be inaccurate
because of these women
We have to calculate the total
fertility rate for Saudi women only
to know exactly how much
the fertility rate decrease in the Saudi society
I looked at the statistical book
for the Ministry of Health
which indicates that the total fertility rates
reach 1.9
which is less than the substitution rate
I don't think it is accurate
It cant rapidly decrease
so, we back to your question
I think it's not good to decline below
the substitution rate level
Because Saudi Arabia is
a developed country,
has an ambitious vision,
needs more population
and workforce
Therefore, we aren't in a country
that prefers low fertility rates
Even countries like Iran
which fertility rates decline under the substitution rate
and tries to encourage...
and I see their statistics
which reaches now above the substitution rate level
May be it's fertility rates is higher
than it in the Kingdom
I imagine someone listen to us
and saying, Saudi Arabia
needs workforce
What about unemployment problem?
More than one million
Saudi male and female
can't find jobs!
so, how do we reconcile
what you say
about Saudi Arabia being ambitious
and need more human resources!
although, human resources
are available today but don't
find jobs!
Well, the existing unemployment
is called structural unemployment
because the unemployed now
with their existing skills; do not fit
with the job opportunities available
in the labor market
and this is a problem,
it is a cumulative problem
came as a result of education
as a result of education planning
over long years
but the vision and its various programs
as The Human Capability Development Program
They are ambitious programs
Quality of Life Program
Hadaf
There are a lot of programs
in the country aim to
rectify this defect
Their is a defect
Their is a defect in graduating
student with skills that are
not needed in the labor market
so, you have to qualify them
and plan for what will come in the future
Unemployment doesn't mean
that we don't need workforce
or we don't have potential
like poor countries, no.
It is only a bad planning in the product
in workforce supply
and I would like to praise the Vision
regarding unemployment, especially female
The vision achieved its objectives
with regard to woman
The percentage or rate
of participation for female was 17%
i,e.
17% of women of working age
participate in labor market
This percentage became 34%
The Vision goal was reach 30%
in 2030
Yes
Now it is 34%, we exceed...
female unemployment rate was really very high
Before 5,6 years was
34%
imagine that
more than a third
of female workforce is unemployed
If we say unemployed
that means a person who is
of working age
and able to work
able to work,
and looking for work
but can't find it
which means, that the 34% are
of work age,
they want to work,
looking for job
but they can't find it.
this percentage dropped
in 2020
to 22%
you can notice
it's a big percentage
22% is high, of course
but it's a huge achievement
and is unexpected
There are considerable efforts in this topic
in women's empowerment in the labor market
remove obstacles,
Allow driving cars for women,
which help them to access their work easily
Anti-Harassment Law
Not requiring the guardian consent anymore
for her to work
Opening new sectors
that were not available to her
All of these things
led to a huge jump in this number
as you said
and it's a wonderful achievement
The question here
since the episode focuses
on the social aspect
What is the impact
of this huge jump
on the social aspects
Because there is a lot of arguments
today on Twitter
Maybe you follow it
A lot of people link divorce cases for example,
fertility rates with female work
First, is this linking accurate?
Second, we go back to the previous question
What is the social impact
for the vast jump
of women's participation in the labor market?
Female  participation
in the labor market must have an impact
but from the economic side,
it is difficult for half of society
to be unemployed
and at the same time,
we hire women from outside of the Kingdom
we hire workforce for jobs
that women can perform
and there are some poor families
who need female labor face
to support their income
Some families don't have sons
thus, women's participation
is a positive aspect
very positive aspect
but we have to create institutions
that save women,
save families,
support families...
How?
For example,
provide affordable kindergartens,
flexible working hours
for some women
remote work
There are many things
that can be done
without impacting family structure
Is this linking correct?
her participation in the labor market.......
Ok, agreed that it has
a positive economic impact
but many link
it to the negative social impact
Is this linking accurate?
In my opinion,
there are pros and cons
and there must be cons Give me examples?
As, increase divorce cases
What is the relation
between female work and increasing divorce?
As reproductive, that we talked about.
Ok.
Can you explain,
what is the relation between her work
and divorce?
her work and delayed reproductive?
Delayed reproductive is obvious.
This is no-brainer
If she is working, especially
if she is ambitious and wants
to work more hours
It would be at the expense
of her decision for reproductive
It's unreasonable to stand out
in her work as a manager or president
in a company or so...
and at the same time,
give birth to a child every year or two
It is almost impossible.
This link is obvious.
Yes.
What is the link to divorce?
For divorce, I think the society
needs a little change
because some husbands
do not accept female work.
especially in a mixed environment
this strains the relation
for some people
and maybe it leads to divorce
if the woman insists on working
in a certain environment
that her husband may not like
but I assume this is a transformational stage
However, if we look at divorce statistics,
we find that there is a rise
in divorce rates over the past years
so that the divorce ratio
has reached 38%
For every 10 marriages, 3 divorces
Yes
It's a high percentage
Before 10 years, it was 23%
This is an exponential decrease.
I interpret this raise as
a corrective condition
Society lives in a corrective stage
How to correct?
I'm going to quote something
related to this situation
You have a fantastic article which was the reason to know you
so, I appreciate it and I recommend it for reading
which was in December 2018, titled
"Social Change and Saudi Society in Light of 2030"
and summarised a set of results
or expected changes in the vision
and its economic and social dynamics
among your mentioned changes
I quote your words:
"Women's earn income
will lead to their independence,
which will reshape roles within the family"
right
and this has a relationship with
our discussion a while ago about the divorce
Explain how woman's income increase
to change her role in the family?
Because the traditional style
is the dependence of wife on her husband.
The financial and l iving dependency
on the husband have a negative side to certain degree
especially in unsuccessful marital relationship
because it makes women
live in injustice.
She has to live with a man
she can't tolerate
The availability of options like
work and others
relief her from unsuccessful married
that may insult her dignity
and this is a positive side
Though divorce is not recommended,
but sometimes it is a solution
for living a good and decent life
So, the increase in divorce cases now
as a result of female work
I see it .....
pursuit of an option
that was not previously available
and it is a corrective situation
means a corrective step
which can be positive
In the future,
because of changes in life patterns,
roles and values.
Social values will change
as part of the huge social change
that Saudi society goes through
This corrective step means
that unsuccessful marriages
can correct their situation
because the regulations allow
and encourage..
In the past, there were women live..
let's say, miserable life because they can't get out
of the golden cage or the metal cage
The regulations enable her to do so now
It's not the regulations only,
having income!
Yes, having income also
give her independence
of course, there is no change
without victims
Even the Vision
has a comprehending that society change has victims
for that, we have Citizen's Account
and others came to ease
the impact of change
on some families
so, there will be a change
on families and children
because the society after going through
the change step
some values are messed up
The society sometimes
lives in a case of value chaos
and some people understand that
the values are disturbed
The old values have been disrubted
and the society create new values
which takes a time
It go through a period of value chaos
Then, start to create values
may differ from the previous values
and this is the nature of societies
We are not alone on this planet
In the same article, you said
"Among changes there will be a leap...
a leap of change in values
and society must harmonise with it,
adjust it and reconcile with it
over time
and education is the magic key"
One of the negative things for me
through following the vision...
There was a value program
Which was called
Develop Citizens' Capabilities Program
Right
It was available, had targets and team
Then, it suddenly evaporated
or vanished
Now, it's added to the
Human Capability Development Program
but we don't see formal
or obvious efforts
of instilling values,
What is the role of the family,
for me as a head of the family?
previously, we were dependent
on the country
to do everything,
education, raising children,
teach us how to pray,
close shops until we go to pray,
and do everything on our behalf
Right
A lot of these roles became
your responsibility today
as a head of the family
father, mother, and sons
The lack of a formal effort
to cultivate certain values
I am the head of the family
what can I do?
The ball is in the court of the head of the family
In the past, the goverment instructed to pray
or not to pray
I mean, it didn't say don't pray
Wear your abaya in certain way
It was a big responsibility
Cover up and so on...
but now, the family have to
cultivate the values
in their children through good examples
I mean, the role models
So, if the father or brothers
are good role models
the family will be good
and coexisting with itself
and with society and not isolated
protecting my family doesn't mean
isloate it from the society
Coexisting with society means
understand the change,
cultivate nobel values in children
and this is a significant effort
we can talk about it easily
but when it comes to application, it is difficult
Are they reasons for not to have
or reduce parents desire to
reproductive
because there is parenting load today
We don't have this problem in the past
the society helps in raising children up,
everything was under control
and everything prohibited wasn't accessible
so, we didn't face the same risk which
exist today
Do you think this is part of it?
I think so
My son said you are lucky
Why?
He said you are lucky
because you raised your children already
He said raising children is difficult now
Indeed, it won't be easy
However, we are not used to
cultivate the correct values
We delegated it to others,
delegated it to others
Now, it is your responsibility
and you have to tolerate it
Because if the government to step in
in some matters related to behavior...
The government has its regulations,
legislates and sets regulations
so, you don't affect others' lives
and you don't harm them
but your life is your own
This is the right direction
because intervening in people's specifics
by the formal institutions
isn't appropriate
There is a family responsibility
and education has to
contribute in cultivating
the noble values
The mosque also is put in the right direction
to cultivate the values
not only performing the worship
There are a lot of things
must occur as a result
of this change
because it's change
so, who will raise the children?
who cultivates the values?
The program you mentioned also
about national identity enhancing
and affiliation
I think it needs more efforts
It hasn't started yet
I want them to start
it's frustrated
We need it and we need
to link it with the heritage
linking it with our heritage
to preserve the identity,
link it to the traditional games
We don't want to change dramatically
so, it impacts our identity
because the identity means
how do others see you?
You are unique; you are Saudi
so, you are unique
They see you different
Also, we have to
cultivate belonging values
national affeliation
It's not my role here to express my opinion,
I am just a speaker I think this part is beautiful
from my opinion, there is a segregation
between identity and values
There are significant
and tangible efforts to enhance the identity
in our customs, cuisine, stories,
heritage and our historical sites
There are great efforts
to enhance the identity
There is a great movement
even in camel club, Saudi falcon club
and exhibitions related to this
There is a great effort in identity topic
but I think there is a lack of the values
at least through my follow ups
and you said in the same article
"among the expected changes
increasing the need
to reformulate religious discourse
and strengthen the connection
of the religious guidelines
with dealings between people
Explain this point
I'll trouble you by asking you
to explain this?
What is the  problem in the past
and what is the difference now?
Unfortunately, the religious discourse focused
on the worship in the past
and formalities,
What does your appearance look like?
how to dress?
and on the rules
It didn't focus on dealing with people
If you go to the mosque,
and someone for example steals your shoes!
How can you imagine someone who is going to do the worship
but didn't have the values to respect others' rights
or cheating
staying for a long time praying like 45 mins
This shows the importance
of cultivating the values
like, work devotion, respect time,
respect others
You can see some contradiction
in society sometimes now
when you come to family gathering
so, sons and grandsons admiring you,
give a respectful kiss in his head
and appreciate elderly
but when he goes out and drives the car
and doesn't comply with traffic regulations,
respect others' rights on the road
and maneuver lift and right
What is the relation between this
and the religious discourse?
Altruism, discipline and respect for others..
Islam religion advice for these...
Fulfil the rights of the road!
Fulfill the rights of the road,
give others their rights,
Avoid cheating  and fraud,
"He who treats us dishonestly
does not belong to us.”
So, you feel that religious discourse
doesn't focus on the dealings in the past
It didn't focus on dealings,
work devotion and quality of work
thus, I feel that religious discourse
has a role in cultivating the values
that we discuss now
the role of the mosque,
it should have a positive role
which isn't like the past forcing people to pray
if they can't due to circumstances, preventing them
the mosque, the school and education
Education should play a more significant role
in cultivating nobel value
not only teaching students
We have to cultivate the nobel values
in young generation
and the family has the great responsibility
What is your opinion
about education role
in cultivating responsibility today?
There is a significant, fast
and consective efforts
but it is a vast duty
and the accumulations from the past
are huge
so, I think we walk in the right direction
but we haven't seen tangible results yet
to reassure us
that they are work in cultivating values
even there is wonderful programms
and a significant change in curruclium
though Covid-19 hit and messed things up
so, I beleive it's affected education greatly
Among the changes that you mentioned
in the same article,
"people accept and want to live in apartments"
What is the relation
between social changes
in the type and choice of housing product?
In the past and now, people prefer
to live in a wide place
and this isn't strange
because we came from a rural culture,
where the wide spaces are
We came from the desert,
as far as the eye can see,
all is your home
So, people used to live in big places,
cosy homes, villas with large area
Now, economic conditions,
maintenance, etc
make people live in apartments
thus, the percentage of Saudi
who living in apartments was small
but their percentage increased now
I think it's 34% now
Even though I'm not sure
may be 29 or 30% lives in villas
30 or 34% in apartments
so, there is a transformation
Now, people have to live in ........
is the motive financial?
means, this is what I can do!
or is it social?
I do not need bigger than this!
It is absolutely a financial motive
means, if he finds a big house with lower maintenance costs
he will take it?
Definitely
I think most of them will take the house
Financial motive is the reason
Therefore, you find
this phenomenon clearer in Riyadh
but in non-major cities, you'll find that villa is the choice
right
so, as the city is getting bigger
as the cost increases
thus, the idea of apartment appears
right
What is the relationship between apartments
and nuclear families?
You talked about transformation
in the form of the Saudi family
from a specific form to the nuclear family
What do you mean
and what is the relationship
between it and apartments?
Saudi family has a major transformation
change over the past 3 or 4 decades
So, the family transformed from
an extended family
which has a husband, wife
and their children
brother also, parents,
and maybe other relatives
In the past,  brothers and their wives
lived in the same house
It could be a son and his parents
This is called extended family?
Extended family. Correct.
They live in the same house.
Means, it extends beyond the frame
of husband, wife and children
So, this  family started to turn
into a nuclear family
which means, husband wife and children
due to many reasons,
the economic factor, is a significant factor
but there are other social factors
people desires for living
changed not like it in the past
Son doesn't want to live in the same house
with his parents when he gets married
even if that house is big
like a palace
He is going to look for
a private house
because the concept of building a family,
privacy, the privacy of the family,
husband and wife,
culturally changed
In the past, the wife accepted to live with parents in law
but now, most wives
don't accept to live
with their parents or brothers in law
So,  this transformation caused
a significant impact on raising children
that we discussed a while ago
on taking care of children
on caring of elderlies
It did a significant change
in the feature of the family
because there isn't somebody
to help you in raising children
or taking care of elderlies
So, you have to live alone
Thus, if you live in an apartment
where husband and wife are work
There will be a challenge
in taking care of parents if they need
which makes them hire a nurse
All of these factors affected it
Since the nuclear family is small
which mostly has couple with a child
this, also, encouraged acceptance
of living in apartments
because it's size is enough
for small families
Living in the city also
and the role of an economic factor
because cost of living is very expensive
In the same context,
the new family topic
which number of children is very limited
and it's related to our previous discussion
about fertility rates
Someone named Fahad Al-Harb said
"Having more than 2 children is suicide."
litraly
I think this is an exaggeration!
I know it differs from family to family
and from person to person
but what is the natural and healthy fertility rates for society?
In demographics studies, there is something
they call it, the desired number of children
Studies of desired number
have been done
and should be conducted
because it shows you
the fertility rates trends in the future
The desired number differs
according to education,
religiosity,
place of inhabitance
either in a rural or city,
socialization, age
There are many differences
but what is the appropriate average?
maybe this is your question,
What is the optimal number per family?
If I ask you, Rima and the audience
you will give me different answers
So, maybe I'm going to say 4 or 5
but you encourage reproductive generally
on your articles, tweets
It's obvious
I encourage reproductive with limits, not without limits
What are your limits?
For example, I suppose that having
more than 4 children
in this situation is large number
large number?
Nowadays, yes
Though, my kids are more than 4
Masha 'Allah
and less than 2 is few....
which affected the substitution ratio badly
little...
but these concepts are
a reflection of our culture
Maybe if I meet you in a while
again, Abu Abduarahman
So, you change your mind
It will change
or you will say 7
Maybe I'll say like Al-harbi
There is a crucial subject
you talked about it a lot
which is the  Demographic Gift
and you had a lecture
The Saudi Arabian Society for r Culture and Arts in 2019
You discussed this topic thoroughly
Tell us about the demographic gift
and why are we lucky in Saudi
and have this temporary window?
that if  we use it wisely
it will have huge impact
or vise versa
The demographic gift
doesn't happen a lot, it only happens once
Now, most the Arab countries
and Saudi Arabia, especially
are live go on  in this demographics opportunity
or demographics window
and it occurs as a result of declining
fertility rates at steady fast rate
with small elderlies percentage
this is reflected in the decline
of fertility rates and reduces
the percentage of young people
as I mentioned before
that decreased from 49%
I mean, the percentage of young people
who are under 15 years of age
to 30% or less, for example
this decrease reduces dependency ratio
dependency of youths
so, the dependency ratio become
decreased and elderlies
dependency ratio is decreased for sure
because we have only 4%
of population are elderly people
So, we have a dependency choice
You mean the most of population
are workforce
It's an opportunity to save
and this will impact the economy
You also have a strong supply of workforce
If we look at ratio and proportion
we see a big percentage
in the working age
so, you have an opportunity,
which is a supply of workforce
You also have an opportunity
to grow the human capital
You can save
because young people are few
So, you can invest in them
in health, education and so on
The result of saving is investment
which is reflected in the financial return
The demographic window
continue for 2 or 3 decades
then, the pyramid will inverted
The proportion of elderlies is increasing
so, the workforce will be fewer
thus, we have to benefit
from this demographic opportunity
through investment in youths
increasing their productivity in the society
preparing them also for the future
or develop policies that fit our needs
Do you remember an international
models that invested well in
the demographic window
and vice versa?
Nothing comes to me now
one of the things that always
related to the demographic window
is the Arabic Fall
It is a result of youth increasing
and their lack of responsibility
or they don't
lose anything
If you don't provide them
work and programms
So, sometimes they cause
riots and disturbances
as what happened in some countries
We can say this is a model
of wasting resources
Countries that benefit from it
are Gulf Countries in my opinion
due to their high potential
They invest,
provide programs,
absorbed them into the labor market
significantly
It avoids the issue of demographic window
and still the efforts
of the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia
and some Gulf Countries
to utilize this with the programs
that I mentioned – recruitment programs
training and development programs
Mash 'Allah
programs that motivate the youths
programs to motivate the youths
to start projects and support them
Hadaf program
they have many programs
to qualify and motivate youths
to develop their skills and gain professional certificates
There are many programs
and I think some youths
do not know these programs
or there is a shortage
in announcing them to youths
Otherwise, the Vision has various programs
The Vision came as a conquer
for the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia
at this time
Imagine that we did not do
anything till now…
It will be a catastrophic
for diversifying sources of income
for developing youths
and qualifying them
for future professions,
improve quality of life, sports…
wonderful things
in the Vision that left fingerprints
and will still do in the future
I believe it is a conquer
and positive side
Whoever does not like
the Vision to a certain degree
applies to him the saying
(Man is an enemy of anything he doesn't  know)
because he doesn't know the Vision goals,
doesn't know its programs,
he doesn't know
but yet talks about it
It is really wonderful
as I read more its documents;
the more I admire it,
admire who stands behind it,
admire the strong and brave decision
that was taken without hesitation
in the right time
The Vision, if you see,
is covering the economy,
empowering woman,
developing workforce in general,
the environment; Green Riyadh,
Green Saudi and  environment police
It is massive
Also, decrease resources consumption
We are left with certain issues
Water…
and this leads us to sustainability
I think the issue of water
needs more efforts
to develop water resources
maybe by developing technologies
for seawater desalination
using solar energy which is available
Of course,
we have rationing water use
We have to put more effort
in developing water resources
because it is the live nerve
in sustainability
There are many questions
or let me leave them to the end
I will try to conclude
with 2 questions
related to the non-Saudi residents
percentage vs Saudi citizens
in the demographics
Today we have
38% non-Saudis
of the total population of Saudi
Crown Prince in his interview
in Ramadan two years ago,
he predicted (not targeted)
by 20230 or 2040
to have 50% non-Saudis
What is the impact
of having this large number
of cultures within the Saudi society?
Everything has positive impact
and negative impact
What is the positive
and what is the negative?
The positive… openness to the world
and Cross-Cultural Couples
The human cannot live in isolation
So, if we have skills, experiences,
and values
there are values, experiences,
and skills that we need
and we have to interact
with them to empower our development
empower our existence
The world becomes a small village
You cannot live in isolation
and for sure we need each other
This is the positive side,
what is the negative one?
Nobody with basic sense
says that we don't need non-Saudis
It's impossible
Even in the US,
What is the percentage in the US,
in France.. all countries
This is the positive side,
what is the negative side?
The negative side
is about the identity,
the national identity,
because it will affect the language,
the identity, the Saudi identity in general.
It affects, if it is not regulated correctly
It might even affect the stability
I mean,
if the ratio increased exponentially,
it might affect the stability
They demand certain rights,
they might demand adopting
certain trends
that might not be suitable
to the society
maybe their behaviors
has a certain degree of openness
that might not be acceptable
to society
Behaviors that contradict our values
Maybe some economic aspects
they control some economic sectors
some professions,
if the citizens are not empowered
But, I think,
the Vision has certain programs
that deals with these big challenges
But, it should be looked at
with high attention and care
because definitely, it will have an impact
positive and negative
we have to evaluate this situation
But, the Vision and its ambitious objectives
will not be realized using
only the local workforce
because there are new fields
to the Saudi society,
you have to attract high skills
Also, tourism
people from all over the world
will come to the society
You have to adopt this change,
and you have to protect
your society and kids
using just what we discussed
to enhance the authentic Arabic values
our organizations, even private,
should have a certain direction
of course optional
as the government cannot force them
but it should come from the national bond
and the nationalist sense
the social responsibility towards this country
they should have contribution
(from social responsibility perspective)
in strengthening national belonging,
supporting the national identity
supporting events taking this orientation
There are big challenges
but we cannot live without challenges
We should have challenges to overcome
and I am sure
that we are capable in this country
with what we have of professionals
The last point I will tackle from the points
that has a social impact;
then I will move on to questions
from friends is about the internal immigration
(migration)
You preside a study specialized
on internal immigration
There are a lot of talks nowadays
about migration of most inhabitance including the big cities
of the kingdom cities to Riyadh;
like Jeddah and AlKhobar
most of them are moving
to live in Riyadh
How do you see such incident
and what it's positive
and negative impact in the long run?
First of all,
Migration is a strange phenomenon
Migration is a positive phenomenon
Positive!
Positive, and it has negativieties
They might not agree with you,
but explain to us!
On the positive side, first,
from a national perspective,
it contributes in coalition,
it contributes in national bonding
inhabitance from the south
comes to the middle and goes to the east
Inhabitance from the east
comes to the west
There is a population infusion
and this has a great impact
that shapes out the Saudi entity,
immigration –
may be we do not think about it
but it caused changes in the society
coalition, converge even in clothing, dialect, language,
habits and in traditions
we know the Southern dialect,
the northern dialect
They understand our dialect
Even the dialect itself
is reformed and changed.
The White dialect now
Because of the immigration
This is the social and national aspect
Migration is an economic balancing factor
How it does that?
By reducing unemployment from one side
and increase employment on other side
It increases the income,
it causes a kind of balance
or reduce the regional gap between regions
because excess workers out there
come here causing the reduction
supply and demand – of income here;
and increase it there
because supply of workforce decreased
So, it causes a balance
and reduces the gap
between directorates
and it played that role effectively.
The problem… the cons…
People tend to have certain imagination,
there is a theory called City Lights
People are attracted to them
This theory was applied in Africa
they used to see the city lights
and dazzled with them,
then they go the city
The problem is that some people
come to the city thinking
that work is available to anybody in the city
then they start coming with skill sets
that are not needed in the market
They come and cannot afford housing,
cannot find a job,
and there is no social solidary
(like in the past) where he comes
and stay with you till he finds a job
then Shantytowns arises
(which was combat here) around cities
living in old districts arises
and now old districts are reviewed
and getting red of them started
because they start being focal points
attracting new migrants
internal from the kingdom
our externals from outside.
And absence of work causes unemployment,
drugs, mendicity,
and even non-ethical behaviors,
and security issues
citizens’ security (not national security)
theft increases, crimes,
house breakouts, cars’ stealing
These are the cons of migration
when it is at a rate higher
than the city capacity
And today; does Riyadh receive migrants
at normal rates or above the normal?
Previously, the yearly population growth
was 8%, and this is a very high rate
This causes even traffic jam,
prices increase for housing and so on
Then, there was a direction
from the government to grow Provinces
Universities are open in Governorates
They open universities in all Provinces
This reduces the migration?
Reduce it to certain limit
Also, Economic Cities (Wa’ad Al Shamal,
Prince Abdul Aziz bin Musa'ed City in Hail,
Jazan Economic City
for basic industries,
King Abdullah Economic City (I think in Rabigh)
all this, and the government direction
was to develop
even King Abdullah – may Allah bless his sole
when he visited Jazan
and try to apologize to certain degree
All this… and even development plans,
in the past,
were encouraging this
but with our real empowerment
They were encouraging
the balanced regional development.
Now after the Vision,
what happen to the migration to Riyadh?
After the vision things are changed
The vision is targeting to develop cities,
this includes the development
of three Saudi cities to be
top 100 cities in the world
among the top 100 cities in the world
This direction involves enhancements
in the infrastructure and environment
enhancement of the entertainment fields,
enhancement in the quality of living
in the city
And honestly,
in this Riyadh city is very lucky
sports tracks,
afforestation for all its roads and streets,
improving infrastructure,
transforming it to smart city
There are huge efforts,
like Neom and the Line
– the smart city to be build
to transform Saudi cities
(Especially, Riyadh, Dammam, and Jeddah)
to the smart cities
Cities that use technology
and reduce (on the citizen)
the troubles of transportation,
going through traffic jams, pollution
reduce pollution….
So, there are huge efforts
to transform Riyadh to smart city
by using Artificial Intelligence,
technology, afforestation, sports tracks for public
However, at the same time,
the plan is to have big numbers
of comers to Riyadh
I hope the big number of come
in stages so the city can accommodate them
Also, there should be development
of the areas around Riyadh city
For example, Huraymila,
Amaaria, Al-Muzahmiya
Howtat.. Howtat Bani Tammim… of course
Howtat Bani Tammim for sure…
should have some changes
and I hope that it will have an airport soon
Airport…
So, you can come to us by plane
By plane.. or you leave the jam here
We move to live there
and come there by plane, car, or train.
So, there are heart-warming wonderful efforts
for Riyadh city
However, the worry is when huge numbers
move to Riyadh; what will happen!
This is not the worry for a lot of people,
especially coming from outside Riyadh
Their worry if I want a city
with all these facilities,
do I need to move from my village
or town to Riyadh?
I need these facilities in my own town
where I am living
Distribution of the mega project,
this is an opinion;
that the mega projects should be distributed
Another opinion think that distribution
of these projects will eliminate
the economic impact
If you put them in one place,
you create a city like London, Paris..
What I forget is that generating jobs
in cities with good infrastructure as Riyadh
is easier and less expensive
than generating job in small cities
And this might be the perspective
of the Vision of focusing on limited cities
because they are the ones
to create jobs, to move the economy
How much is the local production
of Riyadh to the economy?
Although we do not have accurate statistics,
but we do not need statistics
to know that it is primary
in generating many jobs
and it is main contributor into local production
However, I do not think that the Vision
ignore the small cities and towns,
but it aims to empower the economy
and increase the degree of competitiveness
for Saudi economy
Because of you will develop all cities
with the same level and efforts,
it will take long time
and you cannot build an economy
with high degree of competitiveness globally
I'll take a set of questions and comments,
and I want your brief comments
Abu Muhammed,
in order to gain time
Somebody is stating
that financial loss resulting
from divorce is estimated
at SR 3.5 billion in Saudi,
What are the reasons?
You have an article in Sep 2021
about divorce reasons,
you summarized them in;
1- increased complexity,
2- rising costs,
3- increased disputes
The first three are clear,
but then you said conflicting goals
and priorities;
and you said cultural differences.
Can you briefly explain these two?
Cultural differences means the way to choose the wife,
traditional style, I think,
needs fine-tuning.
It needs a degree of openness
in how to meet the wife
there is a big issue,
especially in cities…
somebody comes from Hafar Albatin,
Howtat (as you mentioned),
or Rughabah
Do not forget Rughabah please
This person comes here
and he has daughters…
nobody knows that he has daughters
It is difficult to offer your daughters
for marriage… here is the problem
…. Issue in the marriage..
Some times, because what is offered
to the women is few from men
who want to marry..
So, she might accept to marry a man
who does not fit her educationally
or culturally.
This might result in divorce.
This is cultural differences,
what about conflicting goals and priorities?
How this causes the divorce?
Conflicting priorities…
maybe the man has a priority
to have kids
but her priority might be to work
Also, it might be the degree of openness
Some husbands might not want
his wife to visit her friends
or go to a coffee shop with her friends
On the other hand,
some husbands accept this
So, the differences in accepting
these priorities and concepts caused divorce.
Here is Khalid Al AlSaheikh saying
that Saudi is approaching
the minimum fertility rate
with 2.1 per woman
going below this rate
will result in rapid decline
in population numbers in future
It might reach to a point
where it is difficult to reverse its impact
This rate assumes no immigrants to Saudi. etc
We discussed this point,
but in simple terms
Today, there's maternity leave,
motherhood leave, hours for breastfeeding,
family housing loan
all these motivations exist
and yet the birth rate is declining
If you are asked about this?
I want to say,
that he is exaggerating a bit
The fast impact?
fast and shrinkage
It does not happen like this,
it happen over long period of time
Even if the rate is below 2,
the number of population
will not shrink immediately
it will take long time
because there is something
called momentum force
It needs a decade or two
till the population start shrinking,
it is not fast happening.
20 or 30 years not fast, but the question is
that with all this motivations,
why people do not reproductive.
If today you have the power
of suggesting a law or order
to improve this number,
what will you say? One decision.
First if it is one decision,
I would say that very early marriage
is not good as well as the late marriage
Most of the young generation
would like to build themselves
to have a successful family life
They do not want
to go into a family life
that ends into divorce
This is what they think off.
I am not in favor of pushing youths
to marry haphazardly
Then they will divorce!.
There should be prerequisites
for this step (housing …)
But this leads us to the importance
of cooperation between the couples,
because it seems that the whole load
is on the husbands shoulder.
I believe, life is a cooperation
So, if the woman is working,
then she should contribute…
This will ease the marriage,
ease the reproductive
Because the man feel the woman
is his life partner,
contribute in building the family
the cost of family
… this will ease marriage,
and will ease
to certain degree the reproductive
So, if a decision is to be taken
which is not a real decision,
but encouraging the woman to contribute
because the personal status law
(which was issued recently)
is stating that alimony
is the responsibility of the husband
and it is based on Sharia
and there is no contradiction of Sharia,
but to build a strong Islamic society and a coherent family;
maybe they can find a way
for the woman to voluntarily do this
and I do not think
there is anything in Sharia stopping this
And there is nothing prohibit
putting a condition in the marriage contract
between both parties
that the life will be based on contribution
as far as they both agree
I think this will support the family coherence,
and ease the youth marriage.
I would, also, point to
the high cost of housing Despite the great efforts
which was put by the ministry of housing
(their programs enable
many  youths and families
to own their houses
in Riyadh as well as outside Riyadh)
Really their programs gave many options
which was limited
to the real estate development fund to public
Despite all of this, the issue is
the high cost of lands and housing units
especially those who don't meet the criteria
for Sakani program,
or they want to prepare
before going into marriage.
A family counselor, Thamer AlSaleh,
in an interview on Rotana said
“female work does not have
any benefit to the family welfare
in addition to the issues
of relationships formed
in the work environment,
and the negative spirit
that the woman bring back home
from workplace”
Not in all cases.
I imagine it is
an agreement between both partners
I think the lack of women work
is weakening the woman
and makes her accepts
living in an unsuccessful marriage
and this is an issue,
human dignity is important
especially, we have many stories
of situations where the woman went through tough conditions
So, preventing woman from work
might put her into critical situation.
Sometimes, it impacts the family
may be the marriage is successful
and she is doing a work
that might not be important
and the income is low
In this case, may be she need
to dedicate her time to build the family
She, also, need to have flexibility
in discussing things with her husband
to choose the best model for them
May be there is a model
that fits you Abu Abdulrahman,
a model that fits me,
but not fits other family
It depends even on location,
husband income, marriage harmony
But we cannot say that female work
is not good for the family
This makes the woman
in a week position in front of the man,
and makes her live
under the man's mercy in some case
I will conclude this interesting dialogue
by asking you what message you want
to convey to a lot of people
who are not happy
(including my uncle and many others)
with the social changes accompanying the Visions realization?
What is your message to them?
I would say
that the Vision left its finger prints
on the Saudi society
It makes the life wider
and more pleasant,
women became able to practice many activities
(and so the men)
I think those people
do not know much about the Vision;
and I would advise them
to read the Vision documents
and see the achievements.
Change in general
They love the old situation
and do not like change
What is your comment on the social changes?
Well studied social changes,
slow and adaptive is the best model
Fast changes cause disturbance in values
and in living models
This is why gradual change is the best
This message is in favor of chang
What about the society
going through the change…
What is its role?
If he looks back on things
that was not acceptable 2  years ago
and look at it now
For example female driving,
big percentage of the society
did not accept it, and many even
did not allow to talk about…
Now, majority of females are driving;
and I'm happy about that
(our driver went home
and one of my daughters play the role)
This is a significant achievement
for the family to dispense private drivers
I think there might be good changes
that we do not accept
And this, also, depends on the age
change adoption varies from person to person
However, at the same time,
I hope the Vision as well as the public
put mechanisms to overcome the challenges
because there is no change without a price
We would like to be ready
with minimal damage
to have a smooth change
by having institutions,
supporting the family and its role,
supporting the mosque, as we mentioned
and its role,
universities play its role as well,
even civil institutions,
security institutions to adopt
the change level we are going through
to protect females and families
be fully aware
of how to deal with families…
I think whoever said this,
either did not know the Vision achievements,
or did not think of the situation
if we do not have the Vision
How the Saudi society will coop
with the global changes,
changes in energy demands
I think the change came at the right time,
and rescue the kingdom
Because citizens depended on
the government,
and the productivity was low
Now,
shrink government role
the Vision is empowering self-reliance,
empower productivity,
in supporting the citizen
to enable him to be productive
If the government keeps giving you,
then the productivity will be low,
accepting certain professions will be low
There is no society
that survive
while all people working in professions
are non-citizens
we can have this luxury,
Maybe in the past
but in the long term the society
must change to take responsibility
where citizens do all kinds of work needed
and I believe that the Vision encourages this
establish private business, innovation
It encourage increasing
the Saudi citizen's productivity,
not to depend on public sector jobs,
Innovation is one of the goals
for human resources development programs
and one of the Vision goal
in general,
as it motivates the citizen to innovate,
and stimulate creative ideas
I think the Vision is a great achievement
I will convey this message
to my uncle and all who questions this
I'm not sure if I'm convincing,
but you surprised me with this question,
I did not think
of how to answer your uncle!
++++
Maybe I'll meet you and your uncle
and discuss this
Will be glad to do this
We can fly to Howta airport
and visit you there and have dinner at your home
That will be an honor for me
Thank you, Abu Mohammed
It was a pleasure having you
It is an honor for me to be with you..
Thank you for hosting me
Thank you,
thanks Rima Marzooq, for preparing this episode,
thanks Yasir Al Ghanem (the Cameraman)
in analysis, Anas AlKhalil, in audio...
Editing by Anas Al-Khalil,
and in audio engineering, Muhammad Al-Hassan,
production management, Fahd Al-Qusayr
and Saleh Basalamah,
and supervising of Thamanya Radio, Sahar Suleiman,
This is a Socrate podcast ,
One of Thamanya products for publication and distribution